my opponent tonight is writer and
columnist Lauren dukkha is we need to
know her Teen Vogue magazine column is
called thigh high politics personally I
find ankle high politics much more
flattering for my body type
she wrote the article Donald Trump is
gaslighting America or did she maybe
you're just remembering it wrong she won
the National Arts & Entertainment
Journalism Award in 2015 so I guess I
guess there is an award show I hate more
than the Oscars Loren Duke everybody
good lord this is this is our final show
of 2017 I'm looking back on 2017 and for
me the big story the year it's the year
of the Donald yeah I think it's the
reaction to Tom it's the story of the
year either way it's still the year of
the done I can see that point you see
thanks I already won okay you think it's
the reaction to Donald yeah yes I think
that there's people who are engaged
informed in ways they never were before
and then that reaction is significant
and it's kind of reap democratizing the
country
we're read amah critizing I think so I
think that people are excited there they
are making sure they know what's going
on there they're in touch with their
elected officials they're voting for
sure definitely that's what we saw in
Alabama no you wrote an article that was
entitled the gaslighting of America how
Trump was gaslighting America first of
all how do you get a big gas light
because that sounds like a great way of
effective what do you see that all Trump
doing what did you see happen over the
course of this year yeah I think that
everything that I was concerned about
when I wrote that article has gotten so
much worse it seems kind of quaint
almost in retrospect I think at one
point I had said he begins to undermine
the press and I think no he's just like
everyday
so the undermining is definitely
escalated look he's over
right so gas lighting is a technique
where the victim is made to doubt their
own sanity no it's not and that's what I
think that Tom Trump was doing during
his campaigning continues to do to the
American electorate where he is making
us doubt whether anything is true and it
kind of robs us of a foundation of truth
which is the only way that he can be
held accountable as if we're resisting
from a foundation of information of
facts over feelings I won't accept
somebody else's foundation of truth I
like to build my own foundation
now something I'm impressed by you
engage with the spat with Tucker Carlson
but you're consistently donating in his
name to Planned Parenthood which first
of all I think it's I think it's great
that you're giving back to Tucker I
think Planned Parenthood though is the
wrong choice that guy can't be into that
at all what that guy seems very even
here you can't tell by his constantly
judging face he's totally fine here's
another article looking back on 2017
that I found was interesting sexual
misconduct has no political ideology
except that it's democratic isn't this a
Democrats problem you know I think that
Democrats have certainly been willing to
engage with the problem in a particular
way where they're not making compromises
Al Franken step down John Conyers step
down and there is a total lack of
accountability on the right that is
really troubling but I think we're
seeing a bigger shift and refusing to
accept undermining integrating women
across all different spheres of power
and elected officials should be held
accountable
first and foremost yeah
you're looking for accountability do you
fear that we though are we're comparing
people like Al Franken to people like
Harvey Weinstein and that's dangerous
territory you know I think that we have
to be nuanced about it and we have to be
willing to get into the weeds with
context and and judge each individual
situation but we need to start with a
position of believing women because the
reality of false accusations is a myth
that is such a small percentage of
things and women coming forward see
their lives destroyed see their their
entire selves held up to scrutiny it's
the cost of coming forward it's just so
high and the benefits are so low and I
think as a society we need step one to
be being willing to look at what women
are saying and go through the due
process that is necessary and in the
context of Trump that means an ethics
investigation
[Music]
throw another investigation on the
barbecue ball lord dukkha tell me
something I already know
um Tucker Carlson is what happens when
you leave William F Buckley in the
microwave for too long
thanks for the rescue
Lauren Jukka her TiVo column is called
thigh-high politics the fight continues
opposers are there any three words more
exciting than click and subscribe
yes Hillary shot Lincoln subscribe now
and find out the truth they don't want
you to know and by day I mean losers
looking for YouTube handouts without
clicking subscribe do it